[موسيقى]
النها
يه
ابدا رح تسالني متوقعه
متوقعه كنت اسمعها من اخوتنا المحامين مو
العرب كان رمز كلارك
وزير العدل الاسبق الامريكي من المتطوعين
وكان يعيد على مسامعي باستمرار
انه رغد الوالد سيعدم
لكن انت يعني
مستمره بالدفاع عنا وانا اعرف انك ما راح
تتوقفي
[موسيقى]
ما رايك في في مشهد الاعدام نفسه هو كلب
وهل فعلا كما قيل ان لايران دور في الطريق
التي اخرج بها
او اخرجت بها عمليه الاعدام
المشهد ما شفتها وارفض ان اشوفه الى يومنا
هذا لليوم واذا اقول لك قبل سنتين تقريبا
او ثلاثه بالكثير
كان احدهم احد المقربين يعني احد افراد
عائلتي ليش راح التفصيل معتقد الى هالدرجه
انه اني ماخذ هاي التفاصيل معتقدا انه اني
شفت هاي اللقطه قلت له لا تكمل
ايضا راح اقول لك لا
شفتها وقلتها على التلفزيون في يوم من
الايام
وما راح اشوف
[موسيقى]